[Música]
[Aplausos]
a esta tierra tiene cinco grandes
océanos y 113 mares esto equivale
aproximadamente al 70% de la superficie
de nuestro globo estos cuerpos de agua
han sido una fuente inagotable de
inspiración para la humanidad
a mí me inspiran sus horas las olas se
forman principalmente por la fuerza que
ejerce el viento sobre el agua cada ola
tiene su característica cada ola es
única cada ola puede hacerte sentir una
experiencia inigualable pero también en
cada ola podemos ver los resultados del
consumo desmedido de los seres humanos a
veces imagino cómo llegaron los
pobladores a nuestra tierra y los
imagino sobre olas cristalinas
cierren sus ojos e intenten sentir y
escuchar lo que sintieron nuestros
primeros pobladores
todos los seres vivos sin excepción
estamos relacionados al mar
amo la naturaleza amo mi país siempre
soñé con representar a puerto rico a
través del deporte
sin embargo a los 13 años es que conozco
el deporte del buggy toda pequeña pasé
mucho tiempo en las aguas del mar era
una estrategia que mi madre utilizó para
canalizar las energías de una niña muy
inquieta era muy inquieta no podía estar
quieta con este fuerte puerto rico ha
logrado llegar al 'top ten' del ranking
mundial lleva por los pasados 10 años
haciendo esto tiene medalla de plata en
mundiales puerto rico ha tenido su fiel
representación alrededor del mundo y
esto gracias al deporte este deporte
tiene muchos mitos los rodean muchos
mitos yo escuché muchas voces que
dijeron que este deporte era para gente
que usaba drogas que este deporte era
que lo practicaba solamente los hombres
que este deporte si pensaba vivir leer
me iba a morir de hambre que este
deporte incluso me podía comer un
tiburón si seguía practicando los sin
embargo aprendí que este deporte no es
para gente que usa drogas
contrario este deporte es bien
sacrificado nosotros tenemos que
madrugar tenemos que para poder
aprovechar las mejores condiciones del
mal tenemos que estar a las 5 de la
mañana de pies tenemos que descansar
alimentarnos bien hidratarnos si no
arriesgamos nuestra vida este deporte no
es sólo para gente que usa droga
nosotros tenemos que escuchar la voz del
mar y nuestro corazón nosotros tenemos
que creer en nuestros atletas siempre
apoyarlos ser fiel a de ellos este
deporte no es sólo para hombres este
deporte es como todo en la vida aquí va
a sobresalir quien se dedique y tenga
más energía en el agua este deporte en
una hecho morir de hambre como también
escucho unas voces que dijeron por el
contrario este deporte me ha abierto las
puertas al mundo me hace una mujer
saludable feliz eso me hace una mujer
más que millonaria todavía no me ha
comido un tiburón
y ha tenido mis experiencias con ellas a
corta distancia ciertamente nos han
educado de que los tiburones son unos
monstruos pero no es cierto los
tiburones contribuyen a mantener la
salud de los océanos
los tiburones protegen nuestros corales
mis mayores monstruos que se han
convertido en corrientes que han tratado
de sacarme de mi misión de embajadora
del país han sido de estas tres
corrientes que les quiero mencionar
número uno la corriente del
financiamiento representar al país en
este deporte hace una tarea titánica no
sólo tenemos que invertir tiempo en
nuestras aguas sino que tenemos que
salir a la calle tocar puertas buscar
auspiciadores y tratar de convencer a
esos pensadores de que inviertan a
través de sus atletas en el país en el
mar escuchó constantemente comentarios
como
si es un buen truco este truco te quedó
como rn
esta es mi segunda corriente la
corriente del discrimen
mi gente si yo hago un buen truco lo
puedo hacer bien aun siendo mujer no me
tienen que decir que lo hice como un
hombre si me ven bajando una ola como
esta primero no pueden creer que sea una
mujer y segundo dice de hd salen a lo
que tiene son dos grandes no pueden
decir tan siquiera que tengo varios me
da vergüenza como sexualiza en la figura
de la mujer en los medios prefieren
colocar fotos sexual izando nos que
colocar imágenes que resalten nuestras
cualidades deportivas yo recuerdo una
vez que me invitaron una entrevista y me
pidieron de requisitos que fuera en
bikini en una entrevista de televisión
yo recuerdo que me sentí tan mal me
quedé como que pero ya esta entrevista
que consiste de deporte o de qué
la otra corriente es la corriente de la
basura mi gente somos una sociedad que
estamos muy dependientes al plástico en
el planeta tierra tenemos cinco grandes
giros oceánicos y el del pacífico norte
es el mayor basurero de plástico en el
mundo lo interesante y alarmante de esto
es que el plástico no se degrada el
plástico se foto degrada esto quiere
decir que el sol lo tuesta en parte si
estás pequeña pero continúa estando
nuestros océanos esto es alarmante
tenemos grandes basureros alrededor del
mundo hoy estoy aquí para pedirles que
por favor se unan a mí y nadamos
enfrentemos
estas corrientes salgamos de la
corriente del discrimen no hay excusas
para maltratar a la mujer ni verbal ni
física ni psicológica ni emocional
paremos de minimizar sus capacidades
salgamos de la corriente de lava
a todas y todos podemos consumir menos
plásticos imaginen el sol peto que
usamos solo por costumbre resistamos
reciclemos re utilicemos hace muchos
años tuvo una difícil experiencia en el
mar debido a una corriente en medio mar
adentro
ese día aprendí
que las corrientes están para educarnos
y no para detenernos porque yo pude
salir de esa corriente y estar hoy aquí
frente a ustedes hablándoles estoy
segura que si todos asumimos nuestros
rol como ciudadanos del mundo lograremos
enfrentar estas corrientes el planeta la
casa común el océano cuenta con nosotros
sumergen sé en lo que les apasiona
persigan sus sueños pongan sus talentos
y virtudes en función de su país y verán
grandes resultados gracias
[Aplausos]